MOLLY LAVIK: I want to welcome
you to the Authors at Google.
And tonight, we're talking
about Going Supernova,
the Bold Paths of
101 Superachievers.
And we have this super achiever
superstar panel tonight
with us, and we're
about to introduce them.
First though, I want to get
started with a few very, very
quick thank yous.
I cannot start any of these
without thanking the woman who
graces this cover,
Patty Wagstaff,
one of the greatest aerobatic
pilots in the world,
and on the back cover, my friend
and someone who helped me with
a story template, pilot
Ronald Wayne Trumbull.
Thank you out there in Hawaii.
So with that said, there are
also several people tonight
who made tonight possible.
And you're going to
be hearing from Jeff
Rozic in a moment, who is
our host and very dear friend
and someone that I
admire tremendously.
And he's helping teach
me how to be more Googly,
and I appreciate that.
I also want especially
thank the Googlers
that are here tonight--
what a great company, what
an iconic brand.
It's very exciting.
What we like to do
it at these talks
is really feature the
people who are in the book.
The purpose behind
the book is that I
do believe that
super achievement is
something you can emulate.
So if you could have
an example of the most
extraordinary people
out there doing the most
incredible, phenomenal, game
changing, paradigm shifting,
curve jumping-- I learned
that from Guy Kawasaki,
who, by the way, is my
mentor and someone that there
would be notebook without.
That's what tonight's about,
is saluting people like that
so that you can
emulate their mindset.
And you're going to get to hear
some previews of their story.
And of course, I cannot start
without thank Keith Powers,
someone that I look
up to tremendously.
This book would not probably
have half the people in that
if it wasn't Keith who reached
out to his golden Rolodex
and asked people and introduced
me to people, like Jenny,
and made tonight possible.
And I welcome his wife, who's
here tonight, Lynn Powers,
and their beautiful daughter,
Harmony, who are here.
So thank you so much.
And with all of that said,
a few words from our host,
Jeff Rozic, before
we get started.
So thank you all for
coming out tonight.
JEFF ROZIC: Hi, everyone.
I am your Google host.
And that's all I am,
as far as hosts go.
I work at Google, and
we'll talk a bit more
about my little story later.
I'm truly humbled to be on
this panel of supernovas.
And I just want to thank
you all for coming tonight,
after hours, of course--
those of you who work here
on campus, those who traveled
all across the Bay Area
to be part of this book
event, ad here from all these
very inspiring and
educating people with us.
Molly was one of my business
school professors-- almost 10
years ago, we were
talking about it today.
It's been about 10 years since.
Any class of hers that
she offered, I took.
This was in business school.
And it's because she
wasn't just a teacher.
And those are really
important, too.
But she was also an inspired
educator and connector.
Every single class--
not every semester,
every single class-- she brought
in people to the classroom,
realizing that's probably
the most important value out
of a business education, is to
start meeting people, hearing
real stories, and
connecting with people
who you can work with in
different ways later on.
So it's something she
always did without fail.
She made sure we all knew where
to go see Guy Kawasaki talking
about the art of the start when
he came down to Los Angeles
and made sure we could meet
him if we had a good reason to.
Or other entrepreneurs all
over the Los Angeles area--
just always surrounding us with
great mentors in the business
community.
Just by being here
tonight, I'm 100% sure
Molly would let you
into Molly's gang.
We're all in Molly's gang.
And I'm sure she would let
each of you into it too.
And she would also
make sure that each
of your interactions--
it's not just networking.
It's really
connecting and helping
people in meaningful
ways, whether it's
on a business or
project or an education
or whatever it might be.
That's the one thing
I've learned from Molly.
I'm very humble to be with
our other guests tonight.
But most importantly,
thank you all
for coming out to
talk to us too.
MOLLY LAVIK: Thank you.
Excellent.
Thank you for that.
And now, it is my
extreme pleasure
to welcome to the
stage Guy Kawasaki, who
has another best
seller out there.
It's wonderful.
Guy, thank you for
being my mentor.
Thank you for your
sense of humor
that gets me to laugh
in the darkest of days.
And I know everybody is very
excited to hear from you.
So come on up and
share your wisdom.
GUY KAWASAKI: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
So thank you, Molly.
It's very nice to be here.
I really love Google.
I have to tell
you, I spent a year
working for Motorola, which
was part of Google at the time.
And I had a great time.
And I have some very
close friends here.
So it's always a pleasure.
I feel more welcome
here than, shall I say,
at that Cupertino-based
company, where-- I don't even
dare go there anymore.
So I'll tell you a
little bit about my past.
I worked for Apple
from 1983 to '87.
I was Apple's
evangelist to convince
people to write Mac software.
I left, started some
software companies.
I returned as Apple's chief
evangelist back in 1995,
because Apple was
supposed to die in 1995.
So I came back to help
prevent that from happening.
And then I left in '97
to start another company.
And since then, I've been
a writer and a speaker.
I have started another company.
And then now, I'm
chief evangelist
for a Sydney-based
company called Canva.
And Canva is in the
business of helping
people create online graphics.
So we're trying to
democratize design
so you don't have to
buy an expensive program
and spend days and
days learning it.
So Apple, in my mind,
democratized computing.
And Google democratized
information.
And Canva is
democratizing design.
And so as you can
tell, I love democracy.
So that's why I
aligned with Canva
and I'm Canva's
chief evangelist.
So to the topic of the book
about all these super achievers
and stuff-- I'm kind of
flattered to be in the book
at all.
But I have to tell you.
This is a very good
insight into life,
if you ever think
that you've arrived.
So I won't tell you
who did it tonight.
But tonight, someone
said to me, oh, I
work for the company
that hosts your website.
I said, really?
And she goes, yeah.
And she said, oh yeah.
We have all the stuff
for Rich Dad, Poor Dad.
I'm like, oh my god.
So that's Kiyosaki,
not Kawasaki.
So welcome to my life.
So we not only all look
alike, we also sound alike.
And then she went on to
say, so do you speak much?
And I go, OK.
So that's my life.
It's good.
It's good to have
experiences like that.
As long as you can laugh about
it, you're doing all right.
So if I were to give you
the shorter synopsis of why
I'm in the book, besides
being Molly's friend-- so how
did I achieve
whatever I achieved?
Lots of people have
lots of different ideas,
but my idea is very simple.
I am just willing to work.
I love to work.
I am willing to grind it out.
I don't consider myself smart.
I don't consider
myself visionary.
I just will out work people.
There are people who
are smarter than me.
work harder than me.
But nobody can out work
and be smarter than me.
So I love to work.
I love to grind it out.
I get great
satisfaction out of it.
And that is reflected
in my writing style.
The chapter that I made
is mostly about writing.
And I'll tell you,
the gist of my writing
is I like to vomit out the first
version as fast as possible.
Well, back up.
So I like to have a complete
outline, absolutely down
to the paragraph level.
I have an outline.
And it takes me
months to do that.
And after I have
the outline, then I
want to just vomit it
out as fast as possible.
I want to fill out that outline.
And then I go back, and to use
a very gross metaphor, then
it's a matter of
filtering the vomit.
And so you have to pick out
the undigested chunks of food
to just get to your nutrients.
And that's what you see
in a published books.
Now you're never gonna
read a book of mine, right?
So basically, that's my process.
Get it out.
Remove all the undigested food.
And leave just pure goodness.
And it takes hours and
hours and days and days.
To me, the key is
not good writing.
It's good editing.
That's the difference.
A good writer is a good editor.
And if you have a
concept that writing
is the process of
getting a large advance
from a traditional
publisher-- and now you
bought a beach house
with that advance.
And you're sitting on the back
porch on a windswept beach.
And your kids are
all straight A.
The house is perfectly clean,
all the dishes put away.
Your spouse is happy.
Everything is great.
And you sit down.
And you get a fountain
pen, Mont Blanc fountain
pen with an 18-karat gold nib.
And you sit down to a
stack of parchment handmade
by Tibetan monks.
And you sit there and the words
just flow out from your brain
through your arm, through
your wrist to your fingertips
on your Mont Blanc.
And you write in cursive this
fantastic manuscript, right?
And then you send
that manuscript
to your editor in New
York who drops everything
as soon as it comes in,
shuts off the computer,
shuts off the phone, reads your
manuscript in the next four
or five hours, calls
you up and says,
in the history of my
editorial career-- I've
been an editor in New
York for 30 years--
I have never read a perfect
manuscript until today.
So you get that phone call.
Then he continues on
and says, I talked
to the publicity department.
And we don't know what to do.
We have a big problem because
Charlie Rose and Oprah and 60
Minutes all want to feature you.
And they all want exclusives.
We don't know what to do.
And we don't know
if we should sell
the rights to NPR or to
Discovery Channel or to--
SPEAKER: FOX.
GUY KAWASAKI: FOX.
No, it won't be FOX.
I'll never sell a book to FOX.
I would rather be
poor than be on FOX.
So that is not at
all how it happens.
It is a grind.
It is a brutal grind.
And a lot of people say,
well, why do you write then?
Well, I'll tell you, the
only thing worse than writing
is not writing.
And that's why I do it.
You have to be
quasi-masochistic.
Somewhat OCD to be a writer.
And that's what I
am, in a nutshell.
So I told you the
key to my success.
I told you the
key to my writing.
What else can I tell you?
MOLLY LAVIK: Well, you
could tell everyone
about your new bestseller.
GUY KAWASAKI: Oh.
Oh.
So I have a book called
"The Art of Social Media."
This is a book that I
co-wrote with the person who
I believe is the best social
media person in the world.
And I would put her up
against entire agencies.
So we wrote a book.
It's about-- god, it's
maybe 150 pages long.
It has more than 100 tips.
It's very tactical.
It's how to use
social media, how
to use it as a
marketing platform.
It is not about social
media for social reasons.
If you want to just meet
your friends and roommates
and college buddies
and all that,
this is not the book for you.
This is a book about how to
use social media as a marketing
tool.
And it's very tactical.
It's devoid of duh-isms.
A duh-ism is stuff like "you
need to engage your followers."
Or a duh-is, is "you
need to be transparent."
Or a duh-ism is "you
need a good profile."
If you don't know that by
now, don't read this book.
And so I take it
much, much deeper.
So for example, yes,
you need a good profile.
Duh.
But then I explain that this
is what makes a good avatar.
A good avatar is
a photo, primarily
of your face, if not only
of your face, asymmetric.
Use the rule of thirds for where
you put the eyes, front lit.
And don't take a group shot
with a smart phone of 12 of you
and then crop your
face out because that's
the only part you need.
And that's your avatar, so when
people click on the avatar,
it's all pixelated.
So we go into that
level of detail
on the major issues
of social media.
And it's doing pretty
well, I must say.
MOLLY LAVIK: It's
doing very well.
GUY KAWASAKI: Yeah,
because no one's ever
written a book at
this low level.
If this book were a
computer language,
it would be assembly language,
if you know what I mean.
So that's that book.
I'm not here to pimp my book.
I'm here to pimp Molly's book.
MOLLY LAVIK: Thank you.
GUY KAWASAKI: So
I'm really happy.
And I'm happy to be here.
And Molly's Studs Terkel
done right, maybe.
So you're too young to know
who Studs Terkel is, right?
Do you know?
How many of you know
who Studs Terkel is?
Yeah, well, he
wrote a book where
he profiled people of all
sorts of professions-- what
it was like to be a waiter or
a waitress or a truck driver.
It was a very, very
seminal book in my life.
So that's it.
MOLLY LAVIK: Well, thank you.
Well, Guy's going to be
back to answer questions
in just a little bit.
And let's give him a big
round of applause [INAUDIBLE].
GUY KAWASAKI: Thank you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MOLLY LAVIK: --for his story and
he makes writing a bestseller
sound so easy, but--
GUY KAWASAKI: Easy?
Who said it's easy?
MOLLY LAVIK: Well,
you make it look easy.
Anyhow, I'm very excited
to next introduce
Jenny Alden, who about a year
ago had a really bad year.
JENNY ALDEN: I'll
tell that story.
MOLLY LAVIK: And I'm not gonna
say anything else, so come on
up Jen.
JENNY ALDEN: Hello.
I'm just gonna move
these bottles off.
MOLLY LAVIK: Good idea.
JENNY ALDEN: Sorry, I was in
production in my past life.
Well, first of all, thank you
so much, Molly, for having me.
Thank you, Google.
It's really an honor to get
to speak with you all tonight
and share my story.
When I was first approached
about being in a book
about super achievers, I had
to scratch my head a little bit
and question, what does it
mean to be a super achiever?
And I thought, I think has
something to do with success.
But then that begs the
question, what is success?
Now, I think my definition might
be a little different than most
people on this panel, or
Silicon Valley, for that matter.
But ever since I
was a little girl,
if you asked me what it
meant to be successful,
I would say being happy.
And that's a philosophy I've
held onto my whole life.
But then the real question is,
how do you maintain happiness
in the face of great adversity?
And in 2013, I got to figure
that one out all on my own.
And what I found
were two mottoes
that I really held
onto for my dear life.
And the first one was to have
an attitude of gratitude.
And the second--
it's only temporary.
It's only temporary.
This too shall pass.
So if you read my
story, you'll see
that I had a fairytale wedding.
I married the man of my dreams.
We talked of having
kids and everything
and it looked like my
dreams were coming true.
But 10 months after
this wonderful wedding,
the fairy dust
settled when I was
diagnosed with a brain tumor.
And we found the
tumor incidentally.
I fell off a hammock.
My head banged against cement.
We thought maybe I
had a concussion.
So we went to the
ER to make sure
that there was no internal
bleeding and it was OK.
And I was really annoyed when
I thought I had a concussion.
I thought, what a waste
of a perfect Sunday.
Why am I in an ER?
This is really annoying.
But when the doctor basically
said, hey, good news,
there's no internal
bleeding, but it
looks like you might
have a brain tumor,
I was actually pretty grateful
that I found that out.
I was like, that's
why I hit my head.
That's why I'm here.
And I had this sense
that you know what?
It's going to be OK.
And it turned out to
be the size of a golf
ball in the shape of an olive
in my left temporal lobe, which
is where your verbal logic
and comprehension is.
And it seemed like I
would need brain surgery.
And with brain
surgery came the risk
of losing my ability to speak
and comprehend language.
And the chances were
that I would probably
have about 10
years left to live.
And that would be 10 years
with chemo and radiation.
I completely ignored
that last part.
I just knew in my
heart of hearts
I have another 100 years in me.
As for the verbal logic and
comprehension, I was like,
there's no way they're taking
away my ability to speak.
But if they do, I will
dominate speech therapy
and I will figure it out.
What I knew it that I had no
choice but to be positive.
I thought, there was no
sense in worrying about this
until we cross that bridge.
There was nothing I could do.
So I just was happy.
I hung out with my friends.
I went gluten free.
I worked out more.
I went to Burning Man
and some weddings.
And then I had an open
awake brain surgery
on my one-year
wedding anniversary.
And Dr. Mitchell Berger, with
his incredible brain mapping
technique that he pioneered,
saved my ability to speak
and comprehend.
And it turned out to
be a ganglioglioma.
What a beautiful
word-- a ganglioglioma.
Only 1% of brain tumors
are gangliogliomas.
It will never grow back.
He got the whole thing out.
I didn't need any
chemo or radiation.
And it turned out I was right.
There was not much
really to worry about.
So good thing I didn't waste
all that energy worrying?
That was an incredible
experience for me--
to have that unique
opportunity to have
family and friends, old
and new, come together.
I saw burned bridges mend.
And after that
experience, I just
felt like, I can do anything.
What I wasn't
prepared for was what
happened after my brain surgery.
Eight months later, I found
out that my newlywed husband
started to cheat on me at
the time of the operation.
And what felt like
a double betrayal
was that this girl,
who was sleeping
with my husband for eight
months since I was recovering
from brain surgery,
followed me on Facebook,
was a Facebook friend,
and completely knew
about the whole brain surgery
journey and my wedding photos
and honeymoon pictures
and everything-- was just
totally aware.
And as a female who
loves other women
and supports them and has a
book club with over 100 girls
on my mailing with, it
leaves me tongue tied today
to even-- I can't
wrap my head around.
Who does that to someone else?
So I had just experienced
the best of humanity
with my brain tumor.
I was now slapped
with the worst of it.
And my world was turned
inside out and upside down.
I lost about nine
pounds in one week.
I got a new flock of
wrinkles my facialist swore
was not there the week before.
I had complete insomnia.
My body was flushing with
adrenaline for like a month
straight.
Thank god my mom was there.
She drove me
everywhere, because I
would have gotten in a
car accident for sure.
I was just this numb
zombie who could not
make sense of the world.
But at this time, I also
couldn't ignore the glittering
goodness that I
was experiencing.
I had friends who
sent me flowers,
who sent me baked goods, who
showed up at my door, who
took me for a
mani-pedi or a night
on the town, who spent the night
with me, who just would hold
my hand while I sobbed.
I had people in the
grocery store, strangers,
who would give me a hug when
they just found me sobbing.
And I was like, wow, I feel like
the luckiest girl in the world.
What did I do to deserve these
friends, this family, my dog,
the best dog in the world?
I just couldn't believe
this outpouring of love
that I was receiving.
And every text message
that would just say, hey,
thinking of you,
would lift me up.
Like ants coming together
and lifting up a raft,
my friends, these wonderful
people in my life,
kept me alive.
It's crazy to think
about just a year
and change from now,
there was one night,
in addition to the
infidelity and the brain
tumor and other things,
I had an experience
that induced a form
of long migraine.
And it kind of just
fried my brain.
I couldn't even add
two and two, really.
And I was in bed and
my face was war torn
and my heart was bleeding
and my brain didn't work.
And I just was like, I
have nothing right now.
And I was trying to figure
out how to accidentally die,
because I had heard once
that if you commit suicide,
you come back in your
next life as a hairball.
And I knew there was
no way I could do that.
There was no way to come back
again, as a hairball, no less.
I was just really
trying to figure out
how do I just accidentally not
have to ever wake up again?
But the very next day, my
friend came over and took me out
and I had the greatest time.
I was like, wow, not even
24 hours ago, I didn't even
know if I could
handle this life.
And that was temporary.
And a year and change
later, I am so healthy--
aside from this cold--
healthy and happy
and my world is full
of possibilities.
And so what I want to leave with
you guys tonight, because I'm
sure everyone has their
own thing going on--
it might not be as
cool as a brain tumor,
but something's going on.
And if you can look for
the silver lining in it,
there is one, I promise you.
Even though it's hard
to see right now,
there is a silver lining.
And if you hold onto that
with an attitude of gratitude,
you will soar upward and onward.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
GUY KAWASAKI: I'm glad
I went before her.
[LAUGHTER]
MOLLY LAVIK: Thank you, Jenny.
That always makes me cry to
hear that beautiful story.
GUY KAWASAKI: Note to
self, don't follow Jenny.
MOLLY LAVIK: Now, for the
person who is following Jenny,
it is my pleasure to introduce
Keith Powers, a dear friend.
Please come up and
share your story.
KEITH POWERS: Sure.
All right.
Well, I'm glad she
kept that really light,
because it makes
it so much easier.
So I guess since we're
Google, I thought
I'd package this
as Google speak.
I feel like I'm part
of the extended family.
My wife Michiko works in
Google-- what do you call it?--
People Dev.
And so she's been here
for about five years.
And so my daughter Harmony,
who's in the back there,
learning how to code--
so we're here often,
and we kind of feel like we're
part of the Google family.
And so I thought I'd package
it into risk and package risk
into your 20% time.
And so growing up, I
had role models to me.
I was not what you would call
an overachiever in high school.
It was unlikely that I was
going to go to college.
I stopped doing some
things that I was doing,
but I'll keep [INAUDIBLE],
and ended up basically
getting out of my environment.
And then I took some advice
from some of these mentors.
And two of them
were my brothers.
And when I was growing up, I
saw them traveling the world
and taking all sorts of risks
and following their passions.
And so the first thing
I did after I changed
my environment was--
I was from Boston.
And I said, well, let
me get out of here.
And so I just kept taking
risks whenever I could.
And so whenever there
was a path to go down,
I would always take the
path with the highest risk.
And so at that time, my
20% time was taking risks
and learning about
things and doing things
as passionate about.
And the 80% time was
actually doing work
so I could pay for
those other things.
And I was able to do
that all through my 20s.
And I came out here
when I was about 28,
after taking a trip to Nepal and
spending some time with my wife
trekking and in Japan.
And I landed here.
And then I was trying to figure
out a way-- how do I switch it?
So how do I go from 20% of
doing stuff I'm passionate about
and then grueling the
way-- and I'm a workaholic.
I'm working nonstop.
And it's not because-- it's
just something I have to do.
It's like I can't turn it off.
And so I tried to figure
out how do I switch that?
And how do I make the 80%
the 20% and the 20% the 80%?
But I also wanted to benefit
humanity and do something good.
So I had an idea for startup.
And one connection
point was I went
to a boot camp, one of your
boot camps in '98 or '99.
And I thought, let's
democratize transportation
by letting people who
can't afford a car
and in so they can't get to
work-- let's figure out how
to get people to
work by advertising.
And so I had a company
called Free Car.
And we would wrap cars.
And the whole plan
was to give away
cars with advertising
on them so that they
could pay for
their cars for free
and give it to people who were
driving in demographics who
were driving down the
101 or in the 405 in LA,
but basically get people
to where they need
to be for work for
free with a car.
And then the dot
com bubble burst.
I had sold the company.
But the bubble burst,
and no longer was
it $10,000 to $20,000 with
no inventory on the 101.
So the model kept going,
but essentially, I
kept following my
passions about how
do I do things that
can benefit humanity?
Whether or not you like
advertising or not,
that's a whole
other conversation.
But the fact of how
do you get people
into a free car, which
is really important
if you need to get to work.
But it really changed
when I started
volunteering for the X Prize.
And I'll talk about that.
There's been a whole
bunch of other things,
from going to Cuba and
being on TV in Peru
and doing a lot of stuff.
But when I volunteered
for the X Prize--
and how many people have heard
of the X Prize at this point?
How many people have seen
the SpaceShipOne model
in building 43?
So when I went to work
for them, originally, I
wasn't a space geek.
And I say that with much love
now, because most of my friends
are space geeks.
But I did see
something happening
in the private spaceflight
industry, which
was all these amazing people
were getting involved.
So I went from being
a passive observer--
like, oh, this is cool, this
is going on with space--
to actually an active
seeker of the information.
And in the summer of
2004, I was getting
burnt out on grassroots
presidential campaign
that I worked on
when we accumulated
about 10,000 volunteers in LA.
And that's where I met
Molly and Jennifer.
And we worked on the campaign.
And I get burnt out on that.
And then I was really
getting involved
with-- I loved this space idea.
So first thing that I
did is I said, OK, I'm
going to start a company.
Let's democratize this.
This is crazy.
Not everyone can pay $100
or $2,000 to go to space.
So I'm like space dreams.
And then over the weekend,
I coded up a website.
And I was like, there
will be a lottery system.
You either pay $100 with 1,000
people and you maybe get to go.
Or 100 people at $1,000.
So over the weekend,
I coded it up.
And my wife has always
been super passionate
with my weekend business ideas.
There was safe masks when we
had the problem with SARS.
That was a weekend one
I decided not to do,
because business was good when--
it's like the funeral business.
So I said, no.
That's not a good one to do.
But anyways, I got involved in
the space the space industry
and learning about it and I
joined the X Prize Foundation.
At the time, Peter, who's
an amazing salesman,
he said, oh, we need a
chief marketing officer.
And you'd be great.
You'd be great.
But we have no money.
And so I said, that's OK.
I'll volunteer for four months.
And I turned away a great
job back in New York,
but I never wanted to
move back to New York.
And so I said, let's just do it.
This is too good not to do.
And so I said, I'll
give you four months,
and we'll see what happens
after the election.
And then we'll
take it from there.
And with that four months,
it was just a fantastic
experience.
The foundation was
basically bankrupt.
But we had a whole
bunch of volunteers.
And the way that the foundation
was run at the time--
it was a two-bedroom apartment.
And there was a bunch of
people from International Space
University, which
Peter had helped start.
And they would just kind
of come in any time.
And they would just land there.
And they would be hanging out.
And then we'd have
something to do.
And Peter we come in
and basically would
say, OK, who wants to do this?
Not any questions about who has
the ability or anything else--
and someone would
go, I'll do it.
And then they would just
kind of run with it.
And it might get
done or it might not.
But coming from more of
a business background
and more of a
process orientation,
it was a little interesting
organic organization
to be a part of.
But after the winning of the
spaceship-- of the X Prize,
I was fortunate to have two
teddy bears on SpaceShipOne.
I get put some ballast on it.
And so my wife had two teddy
bears, Huggy [INAUDIBLE]
and another one.
I forget the name.
But one looked like her, and
one kind of looked like me.
And it wasn't a lot
of ballast, but it
was something cute
to put on board.
So we still have
those and they have
stickers on the back of them
now that these teddy bears flew
to space.
And then to just fast
forward, after the winning
of the X Prize by Burt Rutan and
his team, the model switched.
And I went from doing 20% time
to 80%, and I joined full time.
Larry hosted us here
for a tech talk.
We asked him to join
the board that day.
And then Peter and I,
over the next two years,
built the board out to be one
of the best boards in the world
and figured out a strategy of
how to create a-- actually,
Larry really challenged
to us with how do you
create a prize institute
that can do lots of prizes?
So he loved prizes, but
he loved the leverage
of building a prize
institute that does a lot.
So I stayed there for awhile.
And then I've continued
down that path
to find things that I'm super
passionate about that I can
focus my energy on
and be supportive.
And then the 20% time
are things like-- they
keep getting better.
The 20% time keeps getting
better, which is-- remember,
the 20% now is the work time.
But I've found a way to make
the work time more pleasurable.
So my 20% time now is I do
property development in Maui.
So it's a much more
stable long term.
And I have to go there
every several weeks, which
is horrible.
But the point is that I've
tried to switch that around.
And one other connection in
point-- and I'll end on this--
is I've been working with
Jenny now for over a year.
And I joined with a
friend of both of ours
and we launched a prize,
a longevity prize.
And so my 80% time now
is primarily focused on--
besides some startups I work
with-- primarily focused
on longevity and seeing what we
can do to speed the clock up,
because I have this feeling
that it will happen sometime.
We will crack the code.
And it doesn't mean
necessarily that it's eternal.
But we will crack the
code where we understand
how to restore homeostatic
capacity, where we can start
to self heal and we live
longer and healthier.
And actually, it's
the other way.
We live healthier, and as
a result, we live longer.
And so we worked on building
this prize over the past year.
It's a $1 million prize.
We have 20 teams
competing from a variety
of different backgrounds--
different approaches, from stem
cell to genetics to optics.
And it's been super exciting.
And now, as an
offshoot of that, we're
launching an international
profit that will be an umbrella
organization to raise funding,
because one of the things
we've learned, just
like with most science,
is that there's not enough
money that's going in there,
and that the NIH money that goes
in there is about $1 billion
a year, but it's very low risk.
And so there's
some amazing people
working in labs all
over this world.
They don't have enough funding.
And so what they end
up doing is they end up
applying for grants in
areas that they don't really
want to work in.
And it's the worst
thing that you can do.
And so these folks
are in there for 50,
80-- we have some of our teams
who are 60, 75 years old.
And they do amazing
work every single day.
And they're not doing
it because of the money.
They're doing because
they want to find
a breakthrough for humanity.
And so anyways, I guess my
takeaway is I think all of us
have personal stories
of success in tragedies.
And I think embracing the
successes and the things you're
passionate about and
overcoming the challenges is
really important.
And so thanks for having me.
And it's great to be here.
[APPLAUSE]
MOLLY LAVIK: Thank you, Keith.
Thank you for sharing that.
Congratulations to you
both on that prize.
That's amazing.
KEITH POWERS: Actually, I'm 90.
And she's--
JENNY ALDEN: 110.
KEITH POWERS: She's 110.
MOLLY LAVIK: And
Keith will also be
back up in a moment
for our Q&A. And now,
for our grand finale and our
host tonight, Jeff Rozic--
and I just have to take
a moment and tell you
that when Jeff was a
student in my class,
he was like no other student.
I knew that I was witnessing
one of the most brilliant people
out there.
And when he graduated, I put
him on my board of directors,
and it was one of the
best days of my life.
And he has been very
generous with sharing
his brilliance all these years.
And I can't wait
to hear his talk,
and thank you for letting me
share your story in the book.
And so everyone, Jeff Rozic.
[APPLAUSE]
JEFF ROZIC: I wanted to
come in with some really
low expectations after the
last panelists and promise
that, as Jenny joked, when
Molly called and started
talking about a book
about super achievers,
I thought, well, let me see if
I can introduce you to some.
And as I got to understand
the project she was working on
and think back about all the
people I've met through Molly
and then also from what I'd
learned through Molly, which
is just to approach people
and forge natural connections
with people and work
in personal life
and so on-- which is something
I truly learned from Molly--
I thought, well, maybe I have
a little bit of a story here.
Let me think about it.
And if you read the book--
and this is a debt definitely
a plug for the
book-- some patterns
start to emerge, I
think, that Molly,
who gravitates toward super
achievers in her life,
has figured out a handful
of characteristics of people
who consistently achieve things.
And I think the only
one that I could maybe
boast a little right
to play on is one
that we might call not being
afraid to push yourself
outside of your comfort zone.
I think that's
something you'd find
in a lot of people
who just go for it.
And I think you've
heard an element of that
in everyone's story tonight.
For me, my quick
version of that story
is I didn't grow up in an
uncomfortable zone at all.
Thanks to my parents, I grew up
in a pretty comfortable Midwest
suburban upbringing.
I had educational opportunities.
I started off in life
wanting to be a journalist.
But I had a premonition
that Guy would say,
writing is not all
it's cracked up to be,
sometime down the road.
But I was on a very typical
path through school.
And so the only thing that
was really interesting to me
growing up in Ohio
was this dot com thing
that was starting to happen
in the early to mid '90s,
and definitely in the later
'90s on the west coast.
So I was in college
in Cleveland.
And I had started
scheming about how
to get out to the west
coast, the digital media
and entertainment
startup hub that
was first time through
building in America.
So I started packing all my
credits into a few semesters
so I could take some
time off and get
an internship in California.
And I remember firing
off 1,000 or more emails
to pursue an internship.
And I found one with a
technology incubator,
which is a relatively new idea,
at least in the dot com version
that we're now pretty
familiar with-- incubators
and accelerators.
This was late '90s, early 2000s
And I had it all set up.
And then by the time that
January rolled around,
where I was supposed to
move out here and do it,
of course, as we've
all invoked tonight,
the first business
setback occurred.
And that was the first
dot com meltdown.
The incubator was no more.
The internship was no more.
And so I just finished school.
And I had to try to find
the most interesting job I
could find.
And probably the one sub thread
through my life of getting out
of my comfort zone is pursuing
working with startups.
There's no better way to get
uncomfortable than go work
for a startup.
And the most
interesting one I could
find in the Midwest at
the time was a company
that was making
the anthrax vaccine
and selling it to the
Department of Defense.
And that was a very
big topic at that time,
better than working in the
funeral business, I would say,
but not a whole lot better,
especially in the 9/11 time
frame that we're talking about.
So this company
ended up being one
of the best startups
a ever worked for.
It was an old
privatized state lab
that became a commercial
venture, a private company,
and later IPO'ed,
and is now a company
called Emergent BioSolutions,
full of the people that Keith
described, which are incredible
scientists doing work
all across the bio sciences.
And it was just a
great experience
to put myself in positions--
project managing,
scientific research
projects-- I couldn't even
get through astronomy
101, and not
I'm working with brilliant
world class scientists,
and just trying to get
out of my comfort zone
and be around brilliant
people at all times.
And then I went back
to business school
and I met a whole bunch
more people like Molly.
And I chose to do that in
Southern California-- again,
this inclination to get
out here in California
and be part of all these amazing
technology themes and trends
that were happening, now in
the mid 2000s, I guess-- 2004,
2005.
And after business school, I had
an opportunity to join Google.
And that one, I guess,
you wouldn't say
is getting out of
your comfort zone.
It's very much a desirable job
coming out of an MBA program.
So it was kind of a
no-brainer for me.
But it was also the
best of both worlds,
because we're trying to do
something very uncomfortable,
which was sell radio advertising
through Google AdWords
platform, advertising platform.
And I just really love this
idea of a disruptive technology.
And that was a great
experience for a couple years.
And then I actually
chose to leave
Google to work for
a much earlier stage
company in a bigger
marketing role.
And that's a pattern I've had
a couple times over the years--
to go seek out a more high risk,
high reward type situation.
We're treated extremely
well here at Google,
as you probably know
if you work here
and if you've heard about it.
It's very true, everything
you read about this company.
It's an incredible
culture and resources.
So the move to go work for a
startup is not an easy one.
But there's a lot of peers in
this amazing community that
choose to do that.
Or better yet, go forge your
own path within this company
and find a very exciting
entrepreneurial project
to work on.
So long story short,
I chose return
to Google a few years later--
very long story, very short--
after a couple rough years
in the startup world.
And now, I'm doing something
called Brand Lab, which
is actually at YouTube just
up the road in San Bruno.
Has anyone heard of Brand Lab?
It's a customer
experience center
where Google's background
in the advertising world
is on this incredibly
accountable form of advertising
called AdWords.
You always know
exactly what ROI you're
getting out of your search ads.
But we've forced into this
world of brand advertising
which is decades
and decades old.
And we've found that
we need to work really
closely with our big brand
advertisers, our big customers,
show them the love, show them
the brand love, as we say,
and become great partners
with them as they take
on digital marketing in a
sense that we could have
never imagined where we are now.
You have all these social
channels to manage,
and all of these various
audience behaviors and profiles
that we never could have
imagined even five or 10 years
ago across devices
and across content
that we love to consume.
So we're in there every single
day in the Brand Lab working
with our best brand advertisers
to figure out how to reach
and how to engage
this digital audience.
And it's a big
challenge right now.
It's probably a safer challenge
than I've sought in years past,
because I've gone into some
very risky startup situations.
And right now, I've all
the comforts and excitement
of working for Google and having
access to these world class
brands and all these
great marketing teams who
come through our
doors every day.
I don't take that for granted
at all, although I can't help
but wonder, when will the next
time be that I kind of a push
myself out of the comfort zone?
So it's also been a little
bit easier for me, probably,
because I've had
a very easygoing,
compared to some of the other
stories we've heard tonight,
on the personal side of life.
And my wife, we've been
together for about 17 years,
believe it or not--
not married that long.
We didn't get married in
third or fourth grade.
But we've been together
for a very long time
since growing up in high school.
So we've got on these
life adventures together.
And that definitely
makes it very easy.
Sometimes, we just
look at each other,
having moved back
to the Bay Area,
moving all around Boulder,
Colorado, and Southern
California, we just
look at each other,
like what are we doing here?
We have two kids now.
And when are we going to start
moving around and seeking
new adventures
and opportunities?
But I guess we kind
of share that DNA
to pursue-- the pursuit
of the uncomfortable
and always to try to test
yourself in new situations.
So that's the only
thread that I can
find to justify my inclusion in
a book like "Going Supernova."
But if that's truly a
trait, part of the DNA,
of an achiever,
then I will gladly
position myself for that one.
So thanks again for
listening to that story.
MOLLY LAVIK: Thank you, Jeff.
Thank you for being here, too.
Thank you for making it.
Thank you, Jeff, for hosting
and making it possible.
We're going to get into the Q&A.
I need to, of course, though,
thank Valeria, my
very dear friend,
who really tonight--
I wouldn't have
gotten through
tonight without her.
She has saved the
day about 40 times.
Thank you, Valeria, so much.
[APPLAUSE]
So before we start
the Q&A, I just
wanted to say that I am
dedicated to helping each
and every one of you
with your major goals.
And there's not
just the book if you
to decide to get a
copy of the book.
But I've put together an entire
mentorinsight.net tool kit
to help anyone, no matter where
you are at life, super achieve.
And there's an app called Gusto
Career Coach available now
on the iPhone, and hopefully,
very soon on the Android,
as well.
I hope you will take
advantage of these programs.
They're really inexpensive
and they're there to help you.
And call me if I can
ever be of help to you,
because I really do care.
So I know you have
some questions
and you've patiently waited.
So who would like to ask
the first question tonight?
AUDIENCE: The question I
have-- in your new book, "Art
of Social," you advocated for
giving away your book freely
to get bigger distribution.
How do you decide that yourself,
as to what's a good fit?
Or do you just do it if
the opportunity presents
and it survives your
black email box maybe?
GUY KAWASAKI: Yeah.
So in the final three
months or so of a book,
when the Word manuscript is
basically more or less done,
at least in my mind,
I send out a message
through all my social media
channels requesting editors.
Some are volunteer
content and copy editors.
So this announcement goes
to about 10 million people.
And about 500 people say
yes, they want to do it.
I send out 500 people
the Word document.
And about 100 actually
write the comment
and send me back-- hundreds,
literally hundreds of comments.
So I open up each Word
document one at a time.
I've turned on Track Comments.
And I look at every
single comment.
And I fix every one.
So one of things I learned is
I send this out in batches,
because I don't send it out
to all 2,000 people at once,
because if I did that, then
they'd all find the same comma,
that's wrong.
So I want people to find
different bugs every time.
So I send it out in stages.
So I do that.
And then I have
to-- funny Story.
So I've done this several times.
And you'd think, well,
with hundreds of people
and me reading it 50
times, by the time
I send it to copy
edit, it's perfect.
And every time I do this, I
expect the copy editor to say,
in my 30 years of
copy editing, I
have never seen a
perfect book till today.
OK?
So guess what happens.
I send this book out.
And I kid you not, OK?
I kid you not.
It comes back with
2,500 corrections.
And I am just
freaking astounded.
Now, how can this be?
Now, obviously, the
way she counts--
if a comma is in the wrong
place, when she cuts, it's one.
She puts it back, it's two.
So let's be conservative.
Let's say it's 1,250 problems.
Still, my mind is boggled.
So anyway, that goes through.
So now, it's PDF.
It's truly final.
And then what I do
is I say, all right,
so anybody who will
review the book,
I will send the
PDF to right now.
And what happens then is you
get another 2,000 or so people.
And all I ask is that they
fill out an online database
where they put their
website or blog
and approximate
monthly page views.
And just between all
of us, I never check.
I just want people-- if they're
really trying to steal a copy,
I want them to
have to lie and say
that they have this
blog or this website
and they get two
million views a month.
So I never check
that, literally.
So then I send this
out to everybody.
And then of those 2,000 people,
maybe 200 or so write a review.
And the way I figure it out,
if you ever write a book,
if you want to guarantee first
day great reviews on Amazon,
this is what you do.
So Amazon turns it
on-- you'll know
what day-- at midnight Pacific.
So at about 7:00 PM
Pacific that night,
you send an email to
2,000 of these people who
promise to review it
and your beta testers.
And you say, listen, it's
going live in four hours.
Amazon will not let you post
the review till it's live.
So in four hours,
it's going live.
I would really appreciate it if
you'd go and immediately review
it, because I want to
get off to a fast start.
OK?
I go to sleep and wake
up the next morning,
200 five star reviews.
And so that's what I did.
Now, I can't tell you that I was
completely open and transparent
with my publisher, because just
suffice it to say that New York
publishers are not theoretically
trying to seed a lot of copies.
There's an institution
called Net Galley
where you go to NetGalley,
you register to be a tester,
and then you can get the book
through official DRM-protected
means.
So I've used hat last time,
just send them the PDF.
And so that's what I do.
That's the dirty
secrets of what I do.
And many people are
just amazed at how
I get so many reviews
in the first day.
So actually, to tell
you another funny story,
when I figured out
this great method,
I literally have to contact
Amazon and say, listen,
you're not going
to believe this,
but tomorrow morning, there's
going to be 200 reviews.
I don't want you to think
that I have 200 false accounts
and I'm giving myself
a five star review.
These people really
have read it.
You have to just trust me.
Otherwise, Amazon
logically would say, well,
how is it that this book
has sold 100 copies,
has 200 reviews?
The math doesn't work out.
So you have to forewarn Amazon
that this is going to happen.
So that's probably more
than you wanted to know.
AUDIENCE: No, I wanted to
know that and the [INAUDIBLE].
GUY KAWASAKI: OK.
OK.
So that's what I do.
AUDIENCE: So what kinds of
skills, what kind of jobs
do you see in 10, 20 years?
GUY KAWASAKI: You
looking at me, are you?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Or any of the other folks here--
GUY KAWASAKI: Ask
the 90-year-old.
KEITH POWERS: So
personal belief is
that the more
creative kids can be
who are the next
generation of workforce,
the better position they'll be.
I think there's a lot of
things, like basic coding
and other things, that'll
be much more of a commodity.
And the everyday
things that we do now
will be done through
AI and through robotics
and other things.
So the more creative
path kids can
take-- it doesn't mean that they
shouldn't know basic things.
So I love that my daughter is
learning some basic coding now.
But it's just to demystify it.
And so when I first built my
website for-- I wasn't a coder.
It was like FrontPage and it
worked-- back in the '90s,
it demystified the
mystery of the web.
And then I was able to
take that and move on.
So personally, my
belief is that whatever
you can do to make
kids super creative
and think for themselves,
the better off they'll
be long term.
JEFF ROZIC: I think it's
really difficult to predict.
That's a great question.
So I'm doing something a little
bit contrarian in parenting.
And that's to allow
the kids to get
into a whole broad swath of
activities, where I think
the modern parent
line of thinking
might be get them really
focused on a programming
language at age two, three,
four, somewhere in there,
a sport at age two, three, four.
I'm joking, of course.
KEITH POWERS: Really?
JEFF ROZIC: Well,
I can't program,
so I can't ask them to program.
But I really echo
what Keith says.
And I think it applies
even beyond design,
but to all kinds of, I guess,
more micro professions that
are enabled by digital.
But you can be a
designer, and through
any number of web storefronts,
sell your products
to a large enough audience
to make an income on,
but nothing that a mass
brand would consider mass.
And I think that same idea
could apply in education,
for example.
I'm a huge student of education.
I watch how it
changes over time.
And the importance of a teacher
is ever going to go away.
And so all the different
ways that teachers interact
with students--
there's still going
to be some magic number
between one teacher
and a handful, up
to 20 some students,
at a time that's going
to really matter.
So I think a lot of the
original occupations
but in this very
digitized mode, where
you can have a whole career
with a fairly niche audience,
is really interesting
and allows you to still
have your kids pursue
whatever they're actually
really passionate about.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GUY KAWASAKI: So my
theory is more along
the law of big
numbers, where I think
I'd like to expose my children
to as much as possible.
I kind of find it
reprehensible-- two of my older
boys in college-- that they're
almost forced to declare majors
practically in their
senior year of high school.
And I guess if you're going to
be a doctor, I understand that.
But anything else,
I just-- I look back
at what I was in senior
year in high school.
To think that I would have
determined my career based
on the next four years,
other than a doctor,
is just incomprehensible to me.
And so arguably, they
have even broader choices.
So I'm really not
pushing them in any way.
I think they need a good
basic liberal arts college
education, contrary to some
of the people you work with.
And I just hope that in
the law of big numbers,
they get exposed
to a lot of things,
because if you told me my
senior year of high school
that someday I would be
a writer with 13 books,
I would have told
you you were insane.
You've got the wrong kid.
So how do I know?
And I just hope, by
the law of big numbers,
they find something that just
makes them so passionate.
And this may be a reaction to
every Asian gene I have in me,
because-- so when I went to
college in the '70s-- 1970,
not 1870--
[LAUGHTER]
When I was in
college in the '70s,
if you were Asian American,
perhaps like you, as you said,
your parents wanted you to be a
doctor, a lawyer, or a dentist.
And I didn't want
to stick my hand
in any part of any
body, mouth or body.
So there goes
doctor and dentist.
So all that was left was law.
So went to law school
for literally two weeks.
And I just hated
law school so much.
I dropped out of law
school in two weeks.
And so that was a very traumatic
thing-- Asian American,
2,000 generations
of my family worked
to get me to this law school,
and I quit after two weeks.
The only thing left was
suicide at this point.
But I look back, and I think
that was the first time
that my intelligence
showed through,
because many people
practice law for 20 years
and figure out
they're miserable.
I did that in two weeks.
So you just never know.
And it's inconceivable
to me for anyone
to sit here and say I can
tell you what your kids should
be 10 years, because if
we're so smart, how come we
all thought Myspace
would control the world?
Oops.
Right?
So just give them a good, broad
education, let them have at it.
That's my theory.
JENNY ALDEN: I will
say, I don't have kids,
but I was a kid, am a kid.
I have an incredible
mom over there.
And my parents just were
always, we love you,
and we don't care
as long as you try.
I had this unconditional love.
And I notice with my friends
who had the parents who
would frame their straight A's
and expect them to get Harvard
and all that-- they
were so much more
stressed and
fear-driven in life.
And the reason why I
got my wonderful job
and I work with Keith is the man
who hired me, he said, Jenny,
I recognize that you're
joy-driven, not fear-driven.
And that's how I got to be
in the incredible position
that I'm in.
And that was from just
the love from my parents
and saying, as long as you try.
AUDIENCE: Can you
teach super achieving?
Are you just talking
to the winners?
There are lots of people
who did all those things
and are unhappy and
left on the curve,
and these are just
people who happened
to pick the right company
or whatever to go to.
MOLLY LAVIK: I believe with
every fiber of my being
that you can absolutely teach
anyone to super achieve.
And here's why.
The people that-- and I've
now had an opportunity
to talk to thousands of
people that have done this.
And they are some
of the people who
have had the worst that life
has to give them-- that they've
conquered-- people that
didn't even go to school,
not even grammar school, people
that had no money, people that
were imprisoned, and yet,
they turned their life around.
So it's not easy.
And sometimes, the
other thing-- I
have one more thing to tell you.
And it is you can be so close.
And I recently read a book
about this, about being so close
and giving up, and just
how close each of you
could be to your own
super achievement.
And it's the book
"Good to Great"
by Napoleon Hill, his book.
And anyhow, he was
saying he had interviewed
someone who was a gold miner.
And he had been drilling
for gold and he gave up.
He tried and he soul
all his equipment.
Three weeks later, someone
bought the equipment
and found the biggest
gold strike ever.
So it's possible.
It's not easy.
There are certain traits
you need to develop.
And that's what I'm hoping to
do with my mentor insight kit.
I have found five things.
You've heard them talk tonight--
our superstar super achievers--
about stepping out of
your comfort zone, Jenny's
story of transforming
adversity into opportunity.
Self exploration
is another big one.
Something called zigzagging--
you heard Jeff's story.
He was at Google, then he went
Boulder, Colorado, and then
over here.
And now, he's back at the
world renowned Brand Lab.
And of course, Guy--
full throttle focus.
When he's working on a
book, there's nothing.
An atomic bomb could
go off, and that is not
going to derail Guy
Kawasaki, right?
It's nothing.
I'm sure he encounters
all kinds of challenges.
So yes, I do believe
it's possible.
So thank you.
And if anybody needs help
getting started on your way,
or perhaps many of
you are on your way--
if you have a major goal,
please don't give up on it.
And these four
people are examples.
And Keith Powers with
his brilliant strategy--
the X Prize, I was there when
he was getting it started.
And they put together
this battle plan.
It was brilliant.
I don't know how you
did it, but you did.
And you put together the most
renowned board of directors
in the history of the world.
And these are not easy things,
but they're all possible.
Give one more round of applause.
Thank you all.
I know how busy you are.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]